[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm son of
bake i'm from the netherlands and i'm
currently with stop captain's company
as an apprentice
so when i started dancing i just had a
friend who was like
i'm just gonna send you this link don't
know how this is gonna end up
i don't know if you like this but here's
a link to like a
dance course and that was at that time
in netherlands and i just went
and i thought okay i'm just gonna try
this and i really
i really loved it what really helped me
is that
holland dens actually believed in what i
what i could become or what i could do
so i was
invited for a project for i dance
project so i met a lot of disabled
artists there and a lot of teachers
that's also where i'm at stopgap and i'm
a school nurse and i'm at
honesty spiritual center and that was
kind of how
how it really jumpstarted my my career i
think
that's how i got to work with stopgap
that's how i got
to get further to look beyond the
borders of just
my my own country and to really see all
the possibilities that were out there
[Music]
for danceable number two i got to work
with a choreographer from the dutch
national ballet
and we got to make a piece called touch
and that was really a way of
trying to let audiences
see inclusive art in this case
so it's the dutch national ballet so
it's a lot about posture
and the perfect body and
yeah i don't necessarily suit that image
i think my inspiration actually comes
from
my relationship to other people
relationships to one another i'm really
inspired
by actually just by bright colors
but really joyful things and i'm i
really love
just doing what i want and for instance
improvisation
and in improvisation i get a lot of
inspiration
from other people that are there
[Music]
what it brought me so far is working
with
so many different people learning so
much about myself
develop how to also become a
choreographer
how to become more of a dance artist how
to
how to teach as well i really enjoyed
that and that brought me
inspiration but also brought me lots of
knowledge
i know better what i want and where i
want to go
i just want to go and i would just want
to discover
you